welcome back uh today we're going to
talk uh we're going to go through the
lab for chapter 13 uh multiple testing
uh and we're going to focus on um two
main Criterion for multiple testing
familywise error rate and false
Discovery rate um as well as how to
estimate things like false Discovery
rate okay so as usual we have our um our
standard Imports these are all familiar
by now and then we have a few new ones
most of the new ones are these T Test
functions from the scipi stats package
and they're just going to be used to um
to we're going to do a lot of
comparisons that the T Test is a is a
simple comparison so there's a one
sample T Test uh an in a two a two
sample independent T test and then a
paired T Test so IND stands for
independent well stands for related and
then we'll do we use this um mult
underscore or multiple test function
from s from the stats model package to
compute these adjusted P values um okay
so we're first going to uh do some basic
hypothesis test using these T Test
functions so we're going to start off by
um making some data uh and we're what
we're going to do is uh we're going to
look at the one sample test we're going
to have 100 instances of 10 draws of
normal data the first 50 columns are
going to have um mean .5 and the last 50
are going to have mean zero so we have
uh 50% that are you know really true
signal non-zero signals and 50% uh
nulls okay and so the way we you know
we're going to we're going to compute
the T statistic testing whether the um
you know the mean in the First Column of
the data is zero or not and this result
here has an attribute called P value
here the P value value is 93% so that's
actually very far from the usual
threshold of 5% so there's not a lot of
evidence that uh the mean isn't zero in
this column and that may be a little bit
surprising because well we had a a mean
of a half uh for each of the entries
here but I guess this means that we just
don't have a strong signal okay so we
could compute now 100 P values here and
this is where the topic of multiple
comparisons come in we can compute a 100
because we have 100 different columns in
in the data set
okay so let's compute all our P values
so we're going to run a for Loop and
we're going to store all the 100 P
values in our for Loop um and we're
going to look at you know if we choose
to threshold that 0.5 we're going to
just cut the P values at 05 and take a
look at you know how these 100 different
P values behaved so we'll make a little
table a 2 by two table similar to a
table you can see in the textbook
um and we there's typical labels that
are assigned to each cell here so the
way this table is laid out is the
columns indicate whether the uh in truth
the null hypothesis is true or false so
this is like the true version of the
hypothesis and this is our decision
whether we rejected or did not reject uh
H
knot okay so one you know for instance
this number here five here uh there are
five true null hypothesis that we
decided to reject
and uh so that's five out of um 100 so
that's actually a false positive rate
about
um uh of sorry five out of 50 there were
50 true NS and we rejected five and
that's a false positive rate about 10%
so false positive rate can be computed
using this column here um and in the
book we talk later about false Discovery
rate or false Discovery proportion
that's computed uh from this row here so
this in the this letter is usually
called v um for that's the letter given
in the summary and the sum of these two
things 5 + 15 that's usually called R
and the fdp we'll see
later uh is V / R so the false Discovery
proportion if we look at all the ones we
decided to reject we rejected 20 and
five out of 20 of them were false so
about 25% false Discovery positive
proportion so the name of the game in
these multiple comparisons tasks is to
sort of consider these 100 different
hypotheses and make decisions that is
choose a cut like 5% in such a way that
well maybe we we limit the number of
false positives we make or we we limit
the the false Discovery proportion
that's sort of how these things
go okay um so we're going to repeat the
experiment but with slightly higher
signal um so instead of having a 0 five
in the first 50 columns we're gonna have
a one and so as we increase the signal
strength we'd expect we would have uh
more discoveries uh because at least in
the first in the first 50 uh rows but um
hopefully not too many more false
discoveries so we'll recreate the table
with the same cuts um okay and now we
see um well we only have two of 48 false
positives uh that's good the other flip
side of a false positive is is a false
negative and that would be a case where
there really is a signal that is the
null hypothesis is false but we fail to
reject so here 10 out of 50 we the true
well truly false NS that is where there
really is a signal we did not reject so
we have uh false negative right here is
about um
20% okay
so now when we uh have multiple P
values well we saw we're going to make
some false positives right here we did
two out of 50 earlier we did five out of
50 okay so above we saw that if we have
um you know 100 different samples we're
going to get a 100 different P values
and we we got a little feel for you know
the number of false positives one makes
uh in doing 100 tests and a little bit
for the the false Discovery proportion
um look by looking at that summary table
of the 100 outcomes and a decision rule
for each of the 100 outcomes so uh the
field of multiple comparisons what it is
sort of based on is trying to make
decision rules uh and each decision rule
makes one of those tables like this one
above to satisfy certain properties and
one property that people are have been
interested in for some time is the
familywise error rate and this is out of
the 100 decisions we made above the
familywise error rate is whatever
decision will we make what's the chance
we make any false positives so what's
the chance that uh this number is
greater than zero and you can construct
a procedure so that the chance of making
a false positive is say less than 5% now
we already saw that procedure is not
going to be just making the decision at
level 5% for each test because what we
saw very easily that we make we make
false discoveries when thresholding at
5% even if all the 500 hypotheses were
were the null hypotheses were true at 5%
you you expect to make about 25 you'd
probably expect to declare 25 of them
significant yeah so we're going to have
to make a a a stricter threshold for
that and so we have a plot here for we
can compute for independent tests at
least what's the the fanwise air rate as
a function of that threshold which above
was 5% and M is the number number of um
the number of tests so here's a little
plot below
um and we can see you know at using the
what we call the nominal threshold of 5%
even at one hypothesis there's a 5%
chance so the familywise air rate is 5%
but as we decrease the threshold um
we're going to get uh um this this fizer
rate is going to decrease and we see for
about 100 hypothesis we need about uh
even less than 001 in fact need uh
0.005 as our threshold or that would be
safe in any case uh because that's 5%
divided by 100 so what that says is if
you use a
0.005 level for each of the tests then
the chance of getting any false positive
is going to be controlled at 5% yes yes
so clearly that's very strict right
because uh that puts a burden High
burden on the the the the hypothesis
whose null is false or where the
alternative is true because it has they
have to have small P values in order to
to get declared significant or in order
to not reject the no hypothesis uh but
nevertheless you can actually uh you
know there are methods to control the
family rate and we're going to look at
some of those methods so we're going to
use one of the data sets um the uh the
fund data uh from the package using our
low data function and I believe here
there are there are 500 managers or
we'll see some number of managers and
that's the point that's multiple
comparisons is many managers okay um so
first we're going to look at rather than
looking at all of the P values of ones
we're just going to look at a small
sample of of five of them so we'll
compute uh the we'll test whether each
uh fund manager is beating the market
that's whether the returns average zero
or not uh and compute the the uh one
sample T
Test and we see that sometimes the P
values are low and this first manager is
doing pretty well well second manager is
um maybe not doing not having a good
year this year or or didn't have a good
10 years or 10 quarters I think we had
however many observations we have
Jonathan we should try and get the name
of that first manager yes yeah well I
know it but I'm not I won't share with
him you're not going to share okay yeah
okay but yes I'll tell you later so the
um what we're going to do is is look at
some meth how we can take these original
P values and and use a meth to control
the familywise error rate in this case
at 5% two common methods out there are
Bon are called bon Ferron and holes
method that Bon foroni threshold that
was that
0.005% effectively the Bon foron
method it just rescales each of these by
the number of tests we do so if we had
100 fund managers um then this P value
would be converted to 6 instead of 0.006
and that's not less Le than 5% anymore
so they would be rejected would be not
rejected yes yes so it's quite strict so
another method is called the homes
method uh which is Works under similar
conditions for Bon foroni but is known
to be slightly more powerful so let's
just look at those P values for those
corrected P values uh for those two
methods so we use this multitest
function this is the multiple test
function from the stats model package we
give it a set of P values and we say how
to adjust the P values here we'll use
the bond
foroni and
uh the what we get out of that are
decisions like whether to reject the
null hypothesis or not as well as the
adjusted P values so actually this will
tell us how many fund managers there are
because we'll be able to see the the the
correction for p values
shortly so oh sorry we only applied it
to five of them so we'll know here there
were five yeah so it was 0.006 before
now it's 0.003 which is 5 *
okay so here um we see actually even
with only five um five of the fund
managers this first one who looked to be
doing quite well before is is has an
adjusted P value even closer to 5% the
second this third manager who was the
second one who seemed to be doing well
is actually sort of already gone over
the
threshold so the okay the next method is
this this homes method um which the
smallest P value is always at adjusted P
value is always identical to Bon froni
but then subsequent ones get get um get
a little bit remain a little bit smaller
so at the 5% threshold this third
manager would still survive the home
threshold yes yeah that could make a big
difference actually if if bonus is based
on that or something like that and the
other these P values well they adjusted
P values were deemed to be over one so A
P value can't be bigger than one so it's
just been cut off at
one okay so now we see that there are
some managers that seem to do well and a
few others this second one didn't seem
to be doing well uh why don't we start
to look for some comp differences
between
managers so as noted before
um these are the two we talked about
earlier uh one who seems to be doing
well one who does not seem to be doing
well um maybe we could test the
hypothesis that maybe manager 1 is
better than manager 2 so this is
slightly different than the test we did
before where we were checking whether
each manager beat the market by test
comparing to zero and so we need a
slightly different test for that we use
this paired T Test this uh testore well
for related this means um for and for
this test remember as you all have read
in the chapter that the indices
effectively have to be the same for so
if these are trading days or quarters
whatever the index is they have to be
the same for each manager one and
manager two so we can compare how well
manager one does in each in the first
quarter of last year and manager 2 did
in the first quarter of last year and
then again we perform a t test and get a
P value of about 0.04 so that's less
than 5% so there does seem to be
evidence that manager 1 is better than
manager 2 so we might want to wrap it up
there and say we've we've we've found a
better performing manager however well
why do we SW to do this to to run this
test well of course you know we saw that
Manor one was the best Manor two was
apparently the worst um so that's so
there was some sort of data snooping
going on so we maybe should not trust
this one too much so with these five
different managers there are at least
five well there are five to two
comparisons you can make and that's 10
if I'm not mistaken U and so there are
if we were to apply the bond for owning
procedure to the 10 possible comparisons
well this P value would be about. 3 so
that would not be um very strong
evidence um so there are some methods uh
because you know this problem of having
different categorical variables here at
which manager and a and a common outcome
this is a kind of common common problem
or a problem of common interest there's
a few methods out there that that sort
of s take care of all simultaneous
differences so one of them is called
tu's highest significance difference and
what rather than dwell too much on those
we'll just look at the adjusted P values
um and so similar to the Bon fron method
it produces an adjusted P value for each
of the possible hypothesis so earlier we
had five hypotheses and we had each five
different adjusted P values now we have
10 hypothesis because we have 10
comparisons and this
862 we know well that's not exactly the
bonon adjustment it's a little bit
different it's a little bit more
favorable than the bonon adjustment but
it's still not less than 5% yeah um so
there's a nice summary plot of
this you can preate create with this uh
this 2ki object uh and it
produces effective confidence intervals
and I won't they're not exactly
confidence interval but they're
intervals for each um for each manager
or each whatever the categorical
variable is and the way this plot is to
be interpreted is if you see two
intervals that don't happen to overlap
um then they would have a signific a and
that pay would be sign significant in
this table we saw before yeah that's a
nice compact plot in this Cas and it's
actually more compact than the table
because uh well it's not a big
difference when we have five to go from
5 to 10 but if we had if you had 25
managers or 50 managers yeah that's a
big difference
yeah